do you get any sneak pizza with you tell  us about this Jen hi thank you for  having me this genic climb and exhaust  rather than seriously still from what  I've generate it's kind of opportunity  one minute super suspect that it could  be a copy of 35 but obviously these can  be very fine but the other highlighted  because your first participation in July  to be sending a transportation plan  along with it this is a commander rule  is this an attempt by China to show off  its growing military presence in Asia  yes yes um I mean I just I was just  there on site yesterday everybody was  everybody we're still trying to get that  whole show and in place although already  that the ones who were already really  work will a victim basically the  aircraft manufacturers in China brought  the planes of exciting um not just  military there are advances and see  through on display at the show itself in  attracting a lot of attention as well